hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well sometimes
confusion arises in reading Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics book 5 when it comes
to particular justice that is justice
understood as a kind of fairness and as
a kind of equality because Aristotle
will say at the beginning of the
discussion I I'm going to talk about two
different kinds of this but then he goes
on to talk about three and he says very
explicitly that what he's calling
reciprocity we'll come back to that in a
minute
differs from justice and distribution
and in rectification quite often it will
arrive at something different than the
distribution or rectification would and
why is that well at its core the the
term that he's using to antique pet
puntos in Greek means something like
suffering in return the ante in return
in exchange and also to a certain extent
against Capone tous is coming from the
verb which means to suffer to experience
to undergo to have done to one and so
you know
we can think of this as sort of getting
what it is that you've given when we
talk about somebody who is able to dish
it out but not you know take it back and
return like with respect to insults or
sarcasm or something like that we're
saying that there's a lack of
reciprocity and that it's okay if
somebody sarcastic to you to be
sarcastic to them because if they can
dish it out them they can take it that's
saying that there should be reciprocity
there now reciprocity could be in terms
of good things or it could be in terms
of bad things the examples that
Aristotle would use are not covering the
entire gamut of possibility we can think
about friendship and relationships as
being governed by something like
reciprocity rather than commutative or a
rectification Tory just as much of the
time in part because friends are
supposed to be you know giving and
taking more or less equally from each
other even if one friend is a better
person than the other you know there's a
sort of equality of give-and-take the
examples that Aristotle uses that are
that are negative or bad or things like
that where we have to do with bad
actions would be things like where we
say the punishment fits the crime so he
brings up the judge read Malthus this
legendary judge in the underworld who
said that look if you're a really bad
guy and pretty much everybody in the
underworld who's going before red man
thoses is going to be a bad guy you
should suffer what you've inflicted on
other people and I suppose if you have
eternity people suffer that's quite
possible so you know if you look at some
of the the
you know sufferings of some of the
ancient Greek villains not the heroes
but the villains some of these would be
examples of that when we talk about
having the punishment fit the crime now
or poetic justice like somebody who
punches people in the face a lot you
know therefore no provocation whatsoever
somebody comes up to them and punches
them and they're all like yeah you
finally got what you deserved or
somebody who cheats on their spouse
their spouse cheats on them and then
people you know they complain to their
friends and their friends like hey dummy
you cheated on your spouse why shouldn't
they cheat on you
that's this conception of reciprocity of
Justices reciprocity Aristotle specifies
that not every case where somebody is
getting what it is that they gave to
somebody else is necessarily reciprocity
so here's one example that he gets the
officer who strikes a person because
it's part of their duty shouldn't be
struck by them in return so you know
back in the ancient time they used
corporal punishment
you'd actually done something wrong you
deserve two flogging you don't get to
turn around to the officer and then pick
up the stick and flog that and say AHA
you know not just how do you like it but
this is just this is restoring it
because you're getting flawed Ardi in
the first place because you did
something wrong it's part of
rectification or justice or perhaps you
know if you are a flogger I suppose so
there are some cases where Aristotle
thinks that if you're pursuing
reciprocity you will actually do things
that are that are unjust but in many
cases it actually is a third kind of
particular justice error so thanks it
you know it might actually be at odds
with rectification justice the idea that
a rapist deserves to be raped in turn
would be an example of recipe
rather than rectification justice the
the idea that blood feud that somebody
kills one of your relatives now you kill
one of their relatives that would be you
know a similar type of thing somebody
embarrasses you you get to embarrass
them in a similar situation all of those
would be examples of reciprocity with
respect to bad or harmful actions
Aristotle also talks about reciprocity
in terms of something else he talks
about it in terms of economic exchange
this is something interesting to think
about he's not talking about friendship
here he's talking about I give you you
know the shoes that I produce so you
give me a bet and I give you five pairs
of shoes so you give me a bet in return
there has to be some sort of
proportionality that people can more or
less agree upon I give you 12 bottles of
beer you give me 3 heads of cabbage you
say no I think it actually deserves two
heads of cabbage and then we start
haggling back and forth that haggling is
trying to figure out what the proportion
ought to be you know the haggling could
be it yeah your cabbage doesn't look
that good you know I'll take three of
your heads because two wouldn't be
enough because your heads are kind of
small or you know the top leaves are
kind of damaged off the pupils off it
well your beer is a little bit stale you
know they people go back and forth I
know I'm not really a drinker in any
case they're trying to find the
proportion between them aerosol will so
something very interesting here this is
sort of a tangent but it does fit in
with these discussions of justice says
this is where money came from money
allows us not only to be able to
exchange things back and forth it
provides a kind of fluidity by being
something that is not going to rot like
beer or cabbages or even shoes or beds
or you know beds are not very convenient
to carry around to exchange with other
people so money has value you
it facilitates proportional exchange
between people who are providing goods
and services to each other
he says it's kind of like a promise a
promise that we can we can trust in that
will allow us to exchange things more
broadly so I mean if I'm a shoe maker
and a whole bag of shoes a lot it's a
lot more convenient to have a wallet
full of you know leather bronze coins
shoes or not you know I'm less of a
high-end shoe maker I'm not gonna have
silver or gold coins it's a lot more
convenient if I need to go to the grocer
and I need to go to the bed maker and I
need to go to the salt you know a salt
cellar and I want to hit the theater on
the way out these allow us to exchange
things back and forth
now that exchange Aristotle thinks is
part of reciprocity it is governed by
this sense of what is actually thinner
what is actually equal so it can be
equal in the sense of look you hurt me I
hurt you in return or it can be equal in
the sense of there's some sort of
proportion of the goods I give you you
should give me a similar proportion back
or perhaps that guy over there should as
well